bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau cette fuite week-end
comme tous les vendredis nous allons
revenir sur les moments forts de
l'actualité culture loisirs et sports du
département ce qui s'est passé dans la
semaine
pendant 26 minutes au cours de cette
émission nous parlerons musique ou
plutôt sol avec l'artiste galatée
originaire de fontenay le fleury qui
sort son premier cd
mais tout d'abord cette interview
d'aurélia de bissy va certainement
rappeler quelques souvenirs à certains
j'en suis sûr
axel bauer se produisait ce jeudi sur la
scène de la batterie à guyancourt pour
un concert exceptionnel l'occasion de
chanter quelques morceaux de son nouvel
album peau de serpent
jonathan willeman pour les images j'ai
voulu mettre l'accent sur le sur le les
textes je voulais que chaque texte soit
vraiment le reflet de ce que je vis de
ce que je suis ce que je ressens et
c'est là je voulais être au plus proche
de ce que je chantais cet album a
représenté une à la fois une rupture et
un changement avec ce que j'ai pu faire
en tout cas je l' ai perçu comme ça
c'est toujours une continuité mais il ya
une vraie renaissance pour moi à
traverser
et donc j'ai pris de la métaphore du
serpent qui change de peau pour entrer
dans sa nouvelle peau sa nouvelle vie on
va dire symboliquement et puis aussi les
cas il
de serpents et souvent récupérés par le
le monde du rock soit sur sur un blouson
on se rappelle de nicolas sketches dans
sailor et lula qui dit ces deux symboles
mon identité ou alors sur les chaussures
et bien là j'ai une guitare qui en peau
de serpent souvent ce qui ce qui va
m'inspirer en fait c'est un mot et le
mot va ouvrir un univers et ça va partir
comme ça il ya des thèmes interrogatif
sur le le sentiment d'être
2 le combat qui peut se passer entre le
conscient et l'inconscient
qu'est-ce qui nous gouvernent le plus
c'est ce qu'on est inconscient est ce
que ce qu'on est
est-ce qu'on est conscient qu est-ce qu
on cherche comment on navigue là dedans
et ses thèmes qui sont chers dans
l'album qui sont traités dans la chanson
aveugle dont le refrain dit aveugle
régime jusqu'à cette métaphore du ce que
j'ai vécu ma vie complètement
inconsciemment est ce que j'aurai vu
mieux les choses une provocation aussi
créer c'est pour moi c'est aller voir un
peu dans l'inconnu aussi
au sens où tu m'as garder
quoi
je vois
et nous allons rester dans la musique
avec des lattes et le chanteur de soul
originaire de fontenay le fleury qui m'a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour à vous
vous êtes accompagné 2 martial nyatto
votre guitariste et collaborateurs
bonjour à vous martial ou alors avec ce
premier cd j'en parlais dans les titres
de ce sept huit week-ends quel message
voulez vous faire passer dans vos
chansons
mais tout d'abord c'est un message donc
positif donc pour dire que tout est
possible qu'il faut se donner juste les
moyens et de toujours croire en ses
rêves de ne pas lâcher donc les projets
qu'on a et peut-être que ça peut ça
aboutir ça peut aboutir un jour alors
pour entrer un petit peu plus dans le
vif du sujet je vous propose un
d'écouter un extrait de votre chanson je
marcherai on écoute ce n'est pas le sien
dans tous mes rêves
sucré
depuis l'enfance ase
tous les sens ma force c'est gagné
question le temps en espérant la renie
que l'avenir
feint d'avoir à se connaître au plaisir
tous ces sétois
assurée
ça la vie
m
je m'en vais
sans aucun repère
samson
sous 16
sur cette chanson comme je marcherai
l'été c'est un peu le reflet de votre
histoire personnelle à vous voilà
exactement donc par rapport à ce projet
donc le pays qu'on a réalisé avec
martial on a essayé de parler de mon
histoire
donc j'étais ancien basketteur et
j'invite tous dans le coeur la passion
de la musique
mais c'était un peu difficile de mettre
de pouvoir les faire cohabiter les deux
voir exactement d'où le manque parce que
j'avais un manque de temps et c'était
pas vraiment le moment oui je le
rappelle pour nos téléspectateurs en
fait vous étiez basketteur professionnel
mais en france
du côté des pays nordiques et la suède
pourquoi avoir arrêté votre carrière
vraiment par passion ou c'était le
basket aussi c'était un monde qui donc
vous étiez là c'est peut-être non le
basket donc c'est vrai que j'ai donné
quand même à peu près quinze ans de ma
vie au basketball et il fut ardam il
arrive à un moment où je me suis posé la
question de savoir si j'allais continuer
et j'ai préféré continuer de mes études
parallèlement ensuite à la musique est à
l'heure actuelle à vous avez 31 ans
voilà xaxi qui est un petit peu voir
vous êtes originaire de côte d'ivoire
aux six autres autres fontenay le fleury
et vous avez écrit aussi une de vos
chansons va dédier à votre pays natal
voilà notamment en raison des récents
grandes villes comme c'est vrai que
cette chanson me tient vraiment à coeur
avec martial il ya eu des problèmes
politiques en côte d'ivoire comme on
sait je pense que vous avez tous entendu
parler pendant un bon moment et on a on
essaie de faire une chanson pour essayer
de chanter la paix c'est un cri du coeur
un petit peu voilà exactement on n'a pas
vraiment réfléchi on a fait la chanson
très peu de temps c'est quand même voilà
une après midi c'était donc ça pas mal
que ça a vraiment beaucoup plus pour
nous c'était vraiment normal de faire
cette chanson se devait de faire cette
chanson pour nos compatriotes sur
internet vous avez maintenant votre
propre chaîne sur un site de vidéos bien
connu c'est votre première production
vraiment
autoproduite c'est difficile de sortir
du lot avec internet tout d'abord mais
aussi avec tous les concours de chansons
qu'on voit en télé réalité à l'heure
actuelle mais c'est vrai que ça c'est
difficile il faut être suivi moi j'ai la
chance d'avoir martial qui avec moi qui
m'a pris un peu sous son aile parce
qu'il est ingénieur ingénieur de son de
formation et donc on a travaillé sur mon
album
son ep pendant un long moment il
m'appelait un peu sonné les il faut être
vraiment bien entouré parce qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui sort
chaque jour et c'est difficile de se
faire une place
ce premier ep du coup c'est le début
d'une longue suite justement d'albums
derrière vous comptez vraiment vous
investir dans la musique donne
dorénavant voilà ça a pris du temps à se
mettre en place mais là vraiment je veux
faire de la musique
j'espère que ça va continuer comme ça et
vous allez un autre aspect qui est assez
intéressant c'est que vous êtes chanteur
officiel du métro voilà dans les nous
dans les transports du métro parisien
j'imagine comment et l'accueil des
usagers dans le métro ça doit être un
peu particulier de chanter dans une de
mes trop lent mais mais pour moi c'est
vrai que c'était assez bizarre au début
de chanter dans le métro
c'était l'idée de martial qui m'a qui
m'a convaincu parce que pour moi c'était
un peu j'avais un peu stable cette
petite appréhension en me disant je sais
pas j'ai un peu peur je sais pas parce
que les gens vont penser mais l'accueil
est vraiment vraiment très agréable
quand on chante avec le coeur les gens
le ressentent directement et à paris les
gens sont stressés ils ont besoin
vraiment de deux se partagent martial
pourquoi l'avoir poussé justement
délatté aller chanter dans le métro et
parce qu'en fait je pense que c'était un
bon moyen de communication est ce qu'on
rencontre le public n'est pas ce qu'il
ya un public complètement diverses
catégories professionnelles et là
c'était c'était un bon moyen
des faits là comme si son projet
artistique et il ya eu des belles
rencontres justement dans les transports
parisiens non il ya des gens des
personnes qui sont nées vous voir et on
a pu faire un concert à villepinte
grâce à ça qu'on a pu mais vraiment
c'est il ya beaucoup de rencontres d
c'est vraiment incroyable je pensais pas
que c'était l'accueil allait être comme
ça et qu'on allait pouvoir vraiment nous
aider de bons contacts
mais comment vous êtes devenu chanteur
officiel du métro ont passé un casting
comment ça se passe voilà ben non on
passe un casting pendant lesquelles donc
on vous délivre un badge qui vous permet
donc d'accéder jouer du promo dans le
métro mais un casting quand même qu'il
restait très professionnelle avec des
avec et j'ai vue professionnel très bel
accueil au respect de des musiciens et
c'est le bal dont vous parlez c'est
valable vitam aeternam où c'est
renouvelable tous les ans se remet en
question
c'est tous les six mois tous les six
mois
d'accord c'est pour pour voir si
vraiment on est on est motivés mais bon
après c'est vrai que quand on quand on
est connu a passé ses plus c'est plus
agréable vous faut dire aussi que
l'équipe de la ratp nous a un peu pris
au csu la sudatel qui nous ont aussi
permis des faits des scènes à
l'extérieur qui est qui qui démarchent
aussi pour nous au décès de sa petite
rampe et enfin nous y trouverons un
terrain très bien alors juste avant de
nous quitter
je ne résiste pas au plaisir je vois que
martial est venu a compté cette affaire
est un petit morceau de jeu marcheurs et
marcheuses
allez c'est parti
j'ai 27 ans tous mes rêves d'un pleut
des plus sucré vie depuis l'enfance
l'adolescence
ma force c'est gagné défiant le temps en
espérant lamy
ouvre la voie à ce qu'on aime second
c'est sous ces étoiles
je marcherai un sens oui je vous
trouverez plus bas côté sans aucun
regret sans aucun regret
sous ces foires merci bravo
malversations merci bah merci donc on
suivra donc les prochains les prochains
morceaux peut-être du coup n'hésitez pas
à nous faire part de tout cela merci
beaucoup en tout cas tous les éléments
d'appréciation du style ce week-end à
bientôt
il s'appelle hamid cet artiste peintre
via rieuvert hyérois nous a ouvert les
portes de son atelier
vous allez découvrir un monde porteur de
couleurs et surtout de messages mais
aussi le reflet d'une histoire
personnelle
aurélia de bissy et patrick jacques de
dixmude
quand j'étais enfant je pensais qu'à ça
faisait du bo descend en place dès le
peinture est donné j'espère qu'au plus
tard quatre filles et yves court passage
à l'école des beaux-arts beaucoup
d'ateliers
en 14 jan cet inédit sculptures de
peinture la figuration le modèle vivant
on va prendre apprendre les ficelles
c'est l'alchimie la peinture vous
connaître des secrets pour les découvrir
passer par des épreuves ça vient en fait
à part c'est une inquiétude
moi je suis inquiet faut que la nuit le
tabou et réalisé 6,5
un soulagement libération quelque chose
qui apparaissent à partir de ex nihilo
partir de rien on arrive à construire un
livre le projet s'est pas vraiment le
faire de la figuration justement ce
serait de s'en éloigner et en fait de
figuration elle apparaît tel même des
personnages on voit des visages des
regards des yeux tous à cacher le mieux
en fait c'est un voyage à dire j'ai
découvert le fameux bleu des émaux de
neige va parler des des bleus aussi du
portugal etc
mais des comme un signe très important
une profondeur dans ce bleu et un
rafraîchissement inquiétudes profondeur
une invitation a appris
aucun passé sinon pour quelques
finitions mais toujours accédants
parfois à quatre doigts ou les cinq
doigts de la main
forme sa forme tout de suite quelque
chose et rapidement
cette étoile qui des grandes toiles et
grands formats elles sont réagir sont
réalisés en fait quelques heures parfois
trois quarts d'heure une c'est très
rapide
il aime la magie des reflets le peintre
vincent expose ses toiles à versailles
jusqu'au 17 novembre
depuis 50 ans il joue avec les nuances
de couleurs et l'eau des paysages de
france
une belle découverte de quatre nuls à
taux et patrick jacques de dixmude
où
et là je voulais avoir quelque chose de
sombre ici pour avoir un reflet assez
profond pour faire au contraire mieux en
sortir si vous voulez les faits de
lumière sur le
sur le mur jaune le peintre vincent a
choisi dans sa nouvelle exposition de
nous emmener sur les bords des rivières
des marais des sous bois le long des
mers à la recherche du reflet totalement
vivant c'est tellement changeant 7 il ya
toujours quelque chose de surprenant
c'est les reflets c'est magique en
fatigue nettement magique 1 c
il ya des moments où je suis allé plus
voir un endroit qui tient vos mac c'est
là qu'il ya un petit rayon de soleil à
travers la forêt
et c'est tout un univers qui
très belle équipe
petit enfant teurs et pour trouver ce
reflet vincent est cette fois resté en
france il a arpenté les sentiers des
hortillonnages d'amiens et apprécier la
douceur de la dordogne pour capter des
lumières différents par exemple lumière
d'automne d'ile-de-france manière très
douce très très tamisée à à côté de la
lumière du midi ou de la lumière de
bretagne qui pète d'une violence
terrible après un coup de vent
après la pluie on peut avoir des
lumières très forte très froide et puis
au contraire de lumières très chaude
très différents ces sas en sautant 80
toiles sont présentées lors de cette
exposition dont une soixantaine ont été
réalisées cette année même car l'homme
est très productif bien inspiré il peut
peindre une huile d'amande une journée
et cela fait 50 ans que sadibou vous le
savez peut-être le mois de novembre est
la période propice aux plantations
d'arbres à magny les hameaux
l'association sky en transition a
organisé cette semaine une opération de
plantation coopérative
l'objectif reboiser la ville et
alimenter des récoltes futures pour les
associations ce week-end la mairie de
magny les hameaux en partenariat avec
l'association saint quentin en
transition organisée une plantation
d'arbres fruitiers sous forme de
chantier participatif d'une quinzaine de
bénévoles étaient présentes pour aider à
mettre en terre des pommiers des
cerisiers des pruniers et les poiriers
le but informer les participants à
planter des arbres et organisé plus tard
des récoltes au profit d'associations
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de refaire de
l'alimentation locale est gratuite donc
en fait on
on essaie de planter un maximum sur sur
la commune ici on est sûr magny les
hameaux ce qu'on a un partenariat avec
la ville sur cette année on a déjà fait
des récoltes qu'on appelle solidaire
c'est à dire en fait on vient avec
plusieurs adhérents d'associations vient
ramasser les légumes et après on fait
une distribution un peu équitable
c'est-à-dire on en donne aussi au
secours catholique ou à d'autres
associations caritatives
en tout c'est une vingtaine d'arbres qui
a été planté dans la journée pour le
plus grand plaisir des manies quoi qui
voit revivre leurs allées des pommiers
prochainement en 50 ans en transition
qui organise ces plantations depuis 2010
mettra en place des ateliers pressage de
fruits pour produire des jus de fruits
sans plan 100 bio et qui peuvent se
conserver plus longtemps durant ce
week-end de la toussaint tournoi de
poker caritatif se tenait à
montigny-le-bretonneux
il était simple pour jouer il fallait
miser mais des denrées alimentaires
reversés à une association justement au
libéralisme chalco elodie moelle à
montigny le bretonneux les joueurs de
poker ont du coeur
ce week-end le frêne ce poker club
organisait un tournoi au profit de la
boutique alimentaire
le principe était simple chaque joueur
devait ramener au minimum un kilo de
nourriture pour participer au tournoi et
pas de sommes d'argent en jeu ou de prix
à gagner uniquement des joueurs réunis
pour le plaisir et la bonne piste
en fait on fait plusieurs actions au
cours de l'année ont fait le téléthon
fait pas mal de choses comme ça pour la
ville aussi parce que on est en relation
avec la ville avec la ville de
montigny-le-bretonneux
on essaie de faire des choses bien bien
ensemble et du cou
on s'est dit pourquoi pas nous pourquoi
ne pas faire un gros tournoi réunir
beaucoup de joueurs et du coup faire une
bonne action même temps c'était pour ça
que j'apprends qu'il est montèrent sur
montigny en étant on a fait un espèce de
partenariat et voilà c'est sympathique
voire au total plus de 300 joueurs se
sont réunis au gymnase pierre de
coubertin pour ce tournoi
plus de 600 kg de denrées alimentaires
ont été récoltés devant le succès de
l'opération les organisateurs n'excluent
pas de pérenniser l'événement et d'en
faire un rendez vous annuel s'est tué ce
week-end place au sport le club de boxe
thaïlandaise duchesnay est une pépinière
à champions créé en 2009 le team china a
connu une ascension fulgurante et compte
désormais dans ses rangs plusieurs
champions de france qui bénéficie du
premier centre de perfectionnement
espoirs du pays
nous avons rencontré cette génération
dorée avec elodie moines l'été dernier
guillaume bas - participe à son
troisième camp d'entraînement en
thaïlande
vainqueur par ko sur ce high kick de son
premier combat au royaume de siam
l'étudiant de 20 ans a pu prolonger son
rêve avec dix victoires en douze combats
il est considéré comme l'un des espoirs
du muay-thaï français double champion de
france junior amateur dans deux
catégories différentes cet ancien
ceinture noire de karaté monde cette
saison chez les amateurs élite mais ce
n'est en rien comparable avec son
expérience thaïlandaise
ici tu as ton travail
si tu auras ton travail tu te lèves le
matin tu viens le soir tu t'entraînes là
bas c'est entre guillemets ton travail
tu fais que ça de la vie tu te lèves tu
va boxer tu reviens tu manges tu dors
chez la sieste je retourne à la boxe
de l'autre côté du ring alexandre
gonsard n'a connu la défaite qu'à une
seule reprise en l'espace de quatre
saisons
à 20 ans il s'est déjà immerger dans la
culture thaïlandaise lors d'un stage
d'entraînement il ya quelques mois
histoire de sentir le parfum du combat
ultime
à l'autre bout du monde c'est un rêve
depuis qu'on a commencé à pratiquer on a
un peu de
on va d'appréhension parce que c'est
différent c'est en france français en
thaïlande et
les thaïlandais sont des mecs qui ont
choqué
de maintenir cette génération dorée ne
manque pas de talent à ses côtés lors
des derniers championnats de france
amateurs mohamed bouzar a été sacré en
moins de 63 kg pourtant il ya quatre ans
lors de la création du team chahid rien
indiquer ses succès sur le ring le club
commence alors avec seulement deux sacs
de frappe désormais pour se préparer les
yvelinois bénéficie du premier pôle
espoir en france mise en place cette
saison par stéphane geoffrey mais
l'entraînement ne suffit pas il faut une
hygiène de vie mais comme c'est comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est un
sport qui est très fractionnée qui
demande énormément de tonicité et
d'explosivité donc celui qui va fumer un
petit peu qu'il ya une hygiène qui amena
pas de sommeil qui s'alimentent mal
forcément il va revenir aux sources et
et aux valeurs ce cador avoir une un
équilibre et une hygiène de vie saine
leur prochain combat majeur la coupe de
france en décembre
l'occasion de concrétiser l'expérience
thaïlandaise pour la première fois
depuis 1996 les moins de 18 ans de
plaisir participe au championnat de
france de handball
cette compétition se déroule en deux
phases un mini championnat à 6 jusqu'en
décembre et la phase finale à partir de
janvier
et c'est plutôt bien parti pour les
plaisirs oies qui sont deuxièmes de leur
poule
rencontre avec une équipe où cohésion et
rigueur sont les maîtres mots
c'est peut-être de la kiltir leur succès
pas un mot plus haut que l'autre à
l'entraînement les regards sont tous
concentrés sur le même objectif
car pour la première fois depuis 1996
les jeunes de plaisir évolué au niveau
national après trois années passées
ensemble et pour cette nouvelle aventure
le groupe n'a quasiment pas changé
finalement après deux journées le seul
renfort important est sur le banc
l'entraîneur alexandre taillefer a
débarqué d'ivry a pris les commandes du
train plaisir war surtout que ses vues
ancien entraîneur avec ce groupe depuis
deux ans peugeot et l'armée depuis et
donc avait vraiment bien construit
l'état de groupe vraiment et la relation
de confiance entre les joueurs et
d'abnégation
donc ça voilà ça c'était du tout cuit
pour moi et c'était une très bonne chose
parce que bien souvent c'est peut-être
ce qui est plus dur à mettre en place
depuis la première journée de
championnat les plaisirs roy n'ont plus
connu la défaite et démontre match après
match du caractère comme face au leader
boulogne billancourt on faire de 8 buts
à la mi-temps on encaisse le premier but
c'est notre but mais malgré tout ils
continuent à m'écouter
moi j'y crois toujours et on revient on
mène plus à 30 secondes de la fin et
finalement on a de moins donc on
encaisse et dernier but et ont fait
match nul
donc c'est une grosse perte chez le
premier en piste et à l'extérieur donc
ça prouve que c'est l'équipe qui me
voilà qui abandonne pas qui jusqu'au
bout et qui se bagarrer comme moi vous
voit sanchez il faut pas assez dans
l'euphorie du jeu parce que sinon reste
vu le jour
c'est là le problème c'est pour ça faut
continuer toujours à l'entraînement
rester bien jouer la rigueur à la place
d'une saison découverte l'exercice
pourrait se transformer en une aventure
inoubliable
mais pour atteindre la première division
du championnat de france en janvier
prochain et faire partie des 50
meilleures équipes du pays
plaisir va devoir terminer parmi les
trois premiers de sa poule après la
phase aller une 2e place provisoire le
succès semble plaisir war et pour
terminer cette édition évidemment place
à votre agenda du week-end tout d'abord
du sport si vous voulez admirer les
meilleurs pilotes mondiaux de mini z ces
petits bolides à l'échelle 1 28e
vous pourrez vous rendre tout le
week-end au centre sportif robert wagner
de vélizy pour la finale de la coupe du
monde de la discipline se succéderont
poste de pilotage pas moins de 130
pilotes issus de 13 nationalités
différentes
rendez vous samedi pour les
qualifications et dimanche pour les
finales dans les autres rendez vous de
votre week-end il y à de la musique un
concert les ce sont les solis de
villedieu qui joueront voyage au bout de
la nuit
à 18 heures ce samedi à l'auditorium de
l'école de musique de trappes au château
de thoiry vous pourrez assister à des
concerts de flûte de clavecin tout le
week-end
premier rendez vous ce samedi 9 à 21h en
football et également du sport sixième
journée de promotion d'honneur trappe
reçoit le neuvième quincy-voisins au
stade gilbert chance avec les trappistes
troisième coup d'envoi à 15 heures ce
dimanche c'est la fin de ce 7,8 ce
week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi une nouvelle fois
pour ma part je vous retrouverai dans le
cette fuite sport la semaine prochaine
pour à 7,8 sport un petit peu
exceptionnelle à cause du pont du 11
novembre au rendez-vous à 18h15 pour
évoquer leur est de l'arbre vert réservé
uniquement aux femmes d'ici là excellent
week-end sur tv fille